Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Knowledge of literature, nil. Knowledge of philosophy, nil. Knowledge of astronomy, nil. Knowledge of politics, feeble. Knowledge of Christianity, profound. Plays the violin well, is an expert single-stick player,
感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。想要每周收听独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先看系列内容，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。文学知识，零。哲学知识，零。天文学知识，零。政治知识，微乎其微。基督教知识，精深。小提琴拉得很好，是一名出色的单棍击剑手，
boxer and cricketer. Has a good practical knowledge of British history. So reads John Watson's description of my co-presenter, Tom Holland. Oh, Dominic. Adapted. You are too kind. Adapted from his very similar description of Sherlock Holmes. Which makes you Dr Watson.
拳击手兼板球运动员。对英国历史有很好的实用知识。这是约翰·华生对我共同主持人汤姆·霍兰德的描述。哦，多米尼克。过奖了。改编自他对福尔摩斯非常相似的描述。这让你成了华生医生。
It does, unfortunately. I walked right into that, didn't I? You did. Bring your service revolver. Representative of the British middle classes, I'll take that. So yes, today's topic is a fictional character, but one rooted in history and obviously a historical phenomenon in and of himself. And that is, of course, Sherlock Holmes. Tom, Sherlock Holmes Holmes we've had a lot of questions about whether what why a history podcast is doing an episode about Sherlock Holmes haven't we we have um and I think one one way to answer that is with another question from Ian
不幸的是，确实如此。我直接跳进这个坑里了，对吧？是的。带上你的威能左轮手枪吧。作为英国中产阶级的代表，我接受这个设定。所以，是的，今天的话题是一个虚构的角色，但一个植根于历史、显然本身就是一个历史现象的角色。而这个人，当然就是歇洛克·福尔摩斯。汤姆，关于歇洛克·福尔摩斯，我们收到了很多关于“为什么”以及历史播客为什么要出一期关于歇洛克·福尔摩斯的节目的问题，对吧？是的，我们收到了很多。我认为回答这个问题的一个方法是借助伊恩提出的另一个问题：
at Elvis 717 um how much of the view or myth of the Victorian Victorian era stems from the Holmes stories so I think that's a crucial part of it. I think there's a huge sense in which our sense in the 20th century, 21st century, of the late Victorian period is profoundly shaped by Sherlock Holmes. But I think also, I mean, I think you can
来自 @Elvis 717 的问题：“维多利亚时代的观点或神话有多少源自福尔摩斯的故事？”所以我觉得这是其中至关重要的一部分。我认为在很大程度上，我们在20世纪、21世纪对晚期维多利亚时代的理解，深受歇洛克·福尔摩斯的塑造。但我也认为，我的意思是，你可以
say about Sherlock Holmes that he is probably the best, the single best known literary figure ever created globally. I think there's a lot of truth in that. Maybe Jesus would be a possible alternative. But I mean, he is instantly recognisable. And so I think that, you know, you've written about the way that Britain has created all these kind of literary myths.
这样评价歇洛克·福尔摩斯：他很可能是全球有史以来最知名、唯一的最佳知名文学人物。我认为这其中有很大一部分真相。也许耶稣会是一个可能的备选。但我的意思是，他是那种能让人一眼认出的人物。所以我想，你知道的，你曾写过关于英国如何创造所有这些文学神话的文章。
Yes. But Holmes is, I mean, is probably... Holmes is the biggest, without any question. So Holmes is the character who has been portrayed on screen more than any other, by far. I mean, there are thousands upon thousands of screen iterations of Sherlock Holmes, screen and stage. Holmes has spawned a colossal industry.
是的。但福尔摩斯，我的意思是，很可能是……毫无疑问，福尔摩斯是最伟大的。所以福尔摩斯是迄今为止在银幕上被塑造得最多的角色，远远超过其他人。我的意思是，歇洛克·福尔摩斯的银幕和舞台改编作品有成千上万。福尔摩斯催生了一个庞大的产业。
There are Sherlockian studies. There are, I mean, we'll get back to this later, I think, but there are people who purport to believe that Sherlock Holmes was a real person and that Arthur Conan Doyle was merely either a pen name for Dr. Watson or a kind of intermediary. There are tons of spinoffs by very distinguished writers, sort of Michael Dibdin, Michael Chabon, and so on.
有“福尔摩斯学”研究。我的意思是，我们稍后会回到这一点，但有些人声称并相信歇洛克·福尔摩斯是一个真人，而阿瑟·柯南·道尔仅仅是华生医生的笔名，或者某种中间人。有大量由杰出作家创作的衍生作品，比如迈克尔·迪布丁、迈克尔·谢朋等等。
So the Holmes phenomenon is colossal. It is fixed in people's minds, an image of a particular kind of patrician Britishness, I think. And I think you're absolutely right, Tom, that the Holmes stories have become a defining image of the late Victorian and Edwardian. I mean, the cabs, the gaslights, the smog. Which in turn, I mean, they are also a fantastic reservoir
因此，福尔摩斯的现象是庞大的。它在人们的脑海中根深蒂固，我认为这是一种特定贵族式英国性的形象。汤姆，我认为你绝对是对的，福尔摩斯的故事已经成为晚期维多利亚时代和爱德华时代的一个决定性意象。我的意思是，马车、燃气灯、雾霾。这反过来，我的意思是，它们也是一个绝佳的宝库，
for people wanting to study the period. Because the stories are situated at the beginning of all kinds of trends that will then work themselves out over subsequent decades and centuries. So, well, I mean, the idea of the police, for starters, the idea of the detective, the idea of science, all of these are crucial parts of the Holmesian narratives. And Conan Doyle's genius really is to kind of knot these various strands together and create something that in a sense continues to define how people around the world think of London.
供那些想要研究那个时代的人使用。因为这些故事处于各种趋势的起点，这些趋势随后在接下来的几十年和几个世纪中不断发展。所以，嗯，首先是警察的概念，侦探的概念，科学的概念，所有这些都是福尔摩斯叙事中至关重要的部分。柯南·道尔的天才之处，实际上就在于将这些不同的线索编织在一起，创造出某种在某种程度上继续定义世界各地人们对伦敦看法的事物。
Well, London particularly. I think you're dead right about that. So let's give a bit of context. Conan Doyle, well, he's not Arthur Conan Doyle, is he? He starts as Arthur Doyle, and he adds Conan to his surname later. He's from a poor family in Edinburgh. I think a really important thing for understanding some of the later stories is his father is an alcoholic who basically goes mad and ends up, I think, in an asylum. He goes away to Jesuit schools and then loses his faith. He becomes very anti-Catholic.
嗯，尤其是伦敦。我认为你对此看法完全正确。那么，让我们来提供一些背景。柯南·道尔，嗯，他其实不叫阿瑟·柯南·道尔，对吧？他最初叫阿瑟·道尔，后来才把“柯南”加到姓氏里。他来自爱丁堡的一个贫困家庭。我认为理解他后来的一些故事至关重要的一点是，他的父亲是一个酒鬼，基本上精神失常了，最后好像住进了精神病院。他去了耶稣会学校，然后失去了信仰。他变得非常反天主教。
He goes to Stonyhurst and then he goes to a Jesuit school in Austria where magnificently he complains at the lack of cricket facilities. Oh, well, I think cricket is going to play a part in this podcast, which is... Yes, it is. Which is basically one of the reasons I was so keen when you suggested it. Tiresome for some, delightful for others.
他先去了斯托尼赫斯特，然后去了奥地利的一所耶稣会学校，在那里，他非常了不起地抱怨那里的板球设施不足。哦，好吧，我想板球在这期播客中将扮演一个角色，这……是的，确实如此。这也是你提出这个建议时我如此热心的原因之一。对有些人来说很烦人，对另我想这就是我对板球这个主题想说的。
I think that's what I had to say about the theme of cricket. So yes, and then obviously he goes and studies medicine in Edinburgh. And this is the key turning point isn't it with Joseph Bell so Joseph Bell
我想这就是我对板球这个主题要说的。所以是的，然后很显然他去爱丁堡学医了。这就是关键的转折点，不是吗？通过约瑟夫·贝尔，所以约瑟夫·贝尔
is this you know beaky patrician kind of surgeon who is universally regarded
就是这种鹰钩鼻、贵族气派的外科医生，被普遍认为
I think as the inspiration for Sherlock Holmes well Conan Doyle says so himself yeah he says so explicitly I mean I think he writes as much to Joseph Bell
是歇洛克·福尔摩斯的灵感来源。嗯，柯南·道尔自己也这么说。对，他明确地这样说过。我的意思是，我想他写给约瑟夫·贝尔的信中
and basically says you are Sherlock Holmes so people that's slightly disappointing because people love to speculate about these things and they basically Yeah, he says so explicitly. I mean, I think he writes as much to Joseph Bannon. Basically, he says, you are Sherlock Holmes. So that's slightly disappointing because people love to speculate about these things, and they basically can't because Conan Doyle gave the game away. But, I mean, Conan Doyle, so he then becomes a doctor in Portsmouth, I think, then South Sea. Yeah.
基本上就说：你就是歇洛克·福尔摩斯。所以这有点让人失望，因为人们喜欢对这些事情进行各种猜测，而他们基本上是的，他很明确地这么说过。我的意思是，我想他写信给约瑟夫·贝尔时，基本上就说：你就是歇洛克·福尔摩斯。所以这有点令人失望，因为人们喜欢揣测这些事，而他们基本上没法揣测了，因为柯南·道尔把底牌全抖出来了。不过，我的意思是，柯南·道尔，后来他成了朴茨茅斯的医生，我想，然后是南海。是的。
So he doesn't really know London very well. And so, in a sense sense his sense of london is a kind of myth makers idea of london yes it's a sort of he's a victorian richard curtis yes yes he has fog instead of snow yeah exactly um and the thing is that doyle conan doyle i mean conan doyle makes him sound grander doesn doesn't it? He adds the name Conan to Doyle. And he wants to be a writer and he obviously has literary ambitions. And all his life, I mean, Sherlock Holmes famously became this prison from which he couldn't escape because at the same time that he's writing the Sherlock Holmes stories, he's writing what he really loves, which are his
所以他其实对伦敦不是很熟悉。因此，从某种意义上说，他对伦敦的理解是一种“神话制造者”对伦敦的想象，是的，他某种程度上就像是维多利亚时代的理查德·柯蒂斯，是的，是的，他把雪换成了雾，是的，完全如此。嗯，关键是道尔，柯南·道尔——我的意思是，柯南·道尔让人听起来更大气，不是吗？他在道尔前面加了“柯南”这个名字。他想成为一名作家，显然有着文学雄心。而且他一生中——歇洛克·福尔摩斯出名后成了他无法逃脱的牢笼，因为在写歇洛克·福尔摩斯故事的同时，他也在写他真正热爱的东西，也就是他的
historical novels. Have you read The White Company? I have. I love it. Everyone says, oh, it's dreary. No, but I loved it. I read it as a child. And there's a sequel, Sir Nigel, which is brilliant. A Life of Nigel Farage by Tom Holland. It opens with an incredible account of the Black Death moving in on England. Right.
历史小说。你读过《白衣军团》吗？读过。我很喜欢。每个人都说，哦，那本书很枯燥。不，但我很喜欢。我小时候读过。它还有续集叫《奈杰尔爵士》，非常精彩。一本由汤姆·霍兰德写的奈杰尔·法拉奇传记。它的开篇是对黑死病逼近英格兰的惊人描述。没错。
And then you end up with Sir Nigel fighting with Sir John Shandos, who really existed, who was absolutely epitome of English chivalry, and ends with the Battle of Poitiers and the Black Prince. And Sir Nigel captures the French king. So it's set in the Hundred Years' War in the 14th century. But the first one is not quite Hundred Years' War. Am I right in thinking that the Black Prince is doing something to do with Castile? That's right, yes.
然后结局是奈杰尔爵士与真实存在过的约翰·尚多斯爵士并肩作战，后者绝对是英国骑士精神的化身，故事以普瓦捷战役和黑太子收尾。奈杰尔爵士俘虏了法国国王。所以故事背景设定在14世纪的百年战争中。但第一部不完全是百年战争。我没记错的话，黑太子是在卡斯蒂利亚做些什么吗？没错，是的。
Trying to restore the king of Castile or something. Yes. So very... Maybe that... Yeah, that's the White Company, I think. Right. So yes, he wants to do that, doesn't he? Conan Doyle.
试图恢复卡斯蒂利亚国王的统治什么的。是的。所以非常……也许那就是……是的，我想那就是《白衣军团》。没错。所以，是的，他想写那种作品，对吧？柯南·道尔。
That's his dream. And he's written... I'm trying to remember my dates. He's written A Study in Scarlet in 1887. And then he comes back... That's obviously been a big hit. That's the first Sherlock Holmes novel. And then the...
那是他的梦想。他已经写了……我努力回想一下时间。他在1887年写了《血字的研究》。然后他回来……那显然是个巨大的成功。那是第一部歇洛克·福尔摩斯小说。然后……
So this is... You have to put this into context. I don't know if you've seen that brilliant book. Then he does A Sign of Four, I think. A Sign of Four, I think, is a bit... Maybe it's a bit later. I don't know whether he's done some of the stories in between. We'll get written.
所以这是……你得把这放到历史背景中去。我不知道你有没有看过那本精彩的书。然后他写了《四签名》，我想。我觉得《四签名》有点……也许稍微晚一点。我不知道他是不是在中间还写了一些短篇。我们会写。
We'll get attacked by Sherlockians. We will. Well, we're going to get attacked by Sherlockians. There's no doubt about that because we don't know... We're not claiming to be Sherlockians, are we? We're historians who enjoy Sherlock Holmes, but we're not Sherlock Holmes sort of boffins. So I don't know if you've seen that brilliant book
我们会遭到福尔摩斯迷的攻击。会的。好吧，我们肯定会遭到福尔摩斯迷的攻击。毫无疑问，因为我们不知道……我们并不自称是福尔摩斯迷，对吧？我们是喜欢歇洛克·福尔摩斯的历史学家，但我们不是那种歇洛克·福尔摩斯的书呆子。所以，我不知道你有没有看过那本精彩的书，
edited by Philip Hensher about the golden age of the British short story. So it came out last year. And Conan Doyle was in there. And Henry James is in there. And lots of H.G. Wells and lots of people from this era. And Philip Hensher points out that in this period, so 1880s, 1890s, 1900s, going up to the 1910s, short stories were incredibly lucrative. So if you were a writer, you'd make the large part of your income from writing for magazines like The Strand, which is where…
由菲利普·亨舍尔编辑的关于英国短篇小说黄金时代的书。那是去年出版的。柯南·道尔被收录其中。亨利·詹姆斯也在其中。还有很多H.G.威尔斯以及这个时代的大量其他人。菲利普·亨舍尔指出，在这一时期，即18世纪80年代、90年代、1900年代一直到1910年代，短篇小说极其赚钱。所以如果你是一个作家，你的大部分收入将来自于为诸如《海滩杂志》之类的杂志写作，这也是……
The Strand is which is where... The Strand is where, yes, it is. And a lot of these great writers do publish in The Strand, and they're paid the equivalent of tens or even hundreds of thousands of pounds today for a story, and they're reaching this relatively newly literate population. I mean, literate within the last sort of 50 or 100 years. And Conan Doyle is to kind of
《海滩杂志》就是……《海滩杂志》是，是的，确实如此。许多伟大的作家都在《海滩杂志》上发表作品，他们为一篇故事获得的报酬相当于今天的数万甚至数十万英镑，而且他们的受众是相对刚刚获得识字能力的人群。我的意思是，在过去大约50或100年里才识字的人。而柯南·道尔对于
magazines like the strand what dickens was to the novel you know i mean he's he's he's the guy who really sets the whole format ablaze yeah kind of reading that uh once sherlock holmes has taken off um having conan doyle's name on the cover would add a hundred thousand readers yes exactly right you can see why they would be keen to keep Conan Doyle writing Sherlock Holmes. Yeah. I guess, in a sense, Conan Doyle gets fed up with him and chucks him off the Reichenbach Falls with...
像《海滩杂志》这样的杂志，就像狄更斯对于小说一样，你知道的——我的意思是，他是真正点燃整个格式的人。是的，有点像在阅读那种……一旦歇洛克·福尔摩斯火了之后，封面上印上柯南·道尔的名字就能增加十万名读者。是的，完全正确。你可以理解为什么他们会热切希望柯南·道尔继续写歇洛克·福尔摩斯了。是的。我想，从某种意义上说，柯南·道尔对这个角色感到厌倦了，于是把他从莱辛巴赫瀑布推了下去……
Well, the amazing thing is that that period, which is the sort of heroic age of Sherlock Holmes, when he's a new character and when Conan Doyle is really into it, that's only a two-year period, 1891 to 1893. And 1893 is when he publishes The Final Problem, when he basically throws Sherlock Holmes off the Reichenbach Falls. And as far as he's
嗯，神奇的是，那段时期——也就是歇洛克·福尔摩斯的英雄时代，当时他还是个新角色，而柯南·道尔也非常投入——其实只有短短两年时间，从1891年到1893年。1893年，他发表了《最后一案》，基本上把歇洛克·福尔摩斯扔下了莱辛巴赫瀑布。在他看来，
concerned, he created him in 1887, then he did two years worth of short stories, and now he's finished. He never needs to think about Sherlock Holmes again. But, of course, he can't escape. Yes, and doesn't he he kind of he slightly runs out of money yeah I think he set up very I mean he has a very interesting life outside literature so as a young man he he goes on a whaler ship to Greenland
他在1887年创造了这个角色，然后写了两年的短篇小说，现在他结束了。他再也不用考虑歇洛克·福尔摩斯了。但是，当然，他逃不掉。是的，而且他是不是有点……手头有点缺钱了？是的，我想他在文学之外的生活非常有趣。作为一个年轻人，他曾登上捕鲸船前往格陵兰岛，
as I didn't know that that's a good fact and he he goes to the Burr War and he covers um he goes to Egypt doesn't he because his wife has tuberculosis. That's right. And she needs to recover. And he gets kind of embroiled in colonial escapades there. And then he goes to the, he volunteers to fight in the Boer War. He's incredibly keen on the Boer War. He's a big, large, I mean, frankly, overweight man.
我以前不知道这一点，这是个好冷知识。他还去了布尔战争进行报道……他去了埃及，对吧？因为他的妻子患有结核病。没错。她需要疗养。而他则卷入了那里的殖民地冒险活动。然后他去了，他志愿参加布尔战争。他对布尔战争极其热心。他是个身材高大的人，坦率地说，有些超重。
He's a big unit, I think. He's a big unit. He's a big unit. So he doesn't get signed up that he goes and covers it a bit like churchill as a he writes like a six volume history of the boer war or something saying how what a great operation it was yes it was splendid there's nothing to see here move on um but he comes back from that he doesn't he doesn't really get paid for that and so that's when he i think he resurrects yeah well exactly so the boer war i
我觉得他是个壮汉。他是个壮汉。他是个壮汉。所以他没有被正式征召入伍，但他去了并进行了报道，有点像丘吉尔那样。他写了一部关于布尔战争的六卷本历史书之类的东西，赞扬这是一场多么伟大的军事行动。是的，太棒了，这里没什么好看的，大家继续走吧。嗯，但他从那里回来后，并没有真正拿到什么报酬，所以这就是为什么我猜他重新……是的，所以布尔战争，
think ends in i can't remember it ends in 1901 or 1902 but hound of the baskervilles is 1901 yes but but hound of the baskervilles is set before he has fallen off the reichenbach falls with professor moriarty and then he does a story in which it turns out that sherlock holmes had faked his own death and had then gone off to off to Tibet for two years to study with llamas. Yeah. So that's the empty house, 1903.
我想结束于——我记不清了——结束于1901年或1902年，但《巴斯克维尔的猎犬》是1901年的作品，是的。但《巴斯克维尔的猎犬》的故事背景设定在他与莫里亚蒂教授掉下莱辛巴赫瀑布之前。然后他写了一个故事，故事里歇洛克·福尔摩斯原来是诈死，然后去西藏待了两年，跟喇嘛们一起学习。是的，那是《空屋》，1903年。
And then, yes. And then basically he, he rather grumpily, you know, continues to sort of churn out home stories now and again. So right up to, I think the,
然后，是的。接着他基本上有些气恼地（你知道的）时不时地继续炮制一些福尔摩斯的故事。所以一直持续到，我想，
the case book stories, which are the last, pretty much the last stories. And feature Sherlock Holmes fighting German agents. Yeah, it's 1927. In disguise as an American. And some American critic said, Sherlock Holmes seems to have taken down
《案卷》里的故事，那是最后的、基本上最后的故事。其中还包括歇洛克·福尔摩斯与德国特工的战斗。是的，那是1927年。伪装成一个美国人。有个美国评论家说：“歇洛克·福尔摩斯似乎把所有能想到的美国俚语都收集起来了，只要有机会就用。”哦，天哪。
every conceivable American expression and uses them whenever he can. Oh my God. That's like your impersonation. That's like your American impersonation. Yeah, it is. Imagine him. So I suppose the question is question is why that's the real
这就像你的模仿秀。就像你模仿美国人的口音。是的，确实如此。想象一下他那样。所以我想问题是，真正的
question isn't it why does it become so resonant so quickly and what is it about the sherlock holmes stories that gets under people's skin at the time what's it tell us about victorian edwardian readers what's your theory tom well um i think that I think that if you're situating it in the context of the age, you have the existence of police forces. And in England, you're starting to have detectives who are employed for this. You also have people who are starting to experiment with writing about detection. We've had Edgar Allan Poe was the murders in the Rue Morgue. That's basically the first, and the Moonstone, I suppose. Well, the focus is really Paris.
问题在于，为什么这个角色能这么快引起如此强烈的共鸣？歇洛克·福尔摩斯的故事究竟有什么魔力，能在当时深入人心？它向我们揭示了维多利亚和爱德华时代的读者怎样的心理？汤姆，你的理论是什么？嗯……我认为，如果你把这放在那个时代的背景下来看，当时已经有了警察部队。在英格兰，开始有专门受雇从事侦探工作的人。人们也开始尝试撰写关于侦探的故事。我们有埃德加·爱伦·坡的《莫尔街谋杀案》。那基本上是第一部，还有《月亮宝石》，我想。不过重点其实是巴黎。
We talked about this with Agnès Paré in the episode on Paris, that there is this sense of criminals and detectives engaged in titanic battles kind of in the sewers of Paris and, you know, in the grand apartments and so on. And that's what Poe is then buying into when he sets his, I think he does three detective stories and they're set in Paris. What's the detective called? Is it Arsene? It's Dupin. Dupinsene? It's Dupin. Dupin, yeah, it's Dupin, exactly. And Poe gets bored of that very quickly. You also have Dickens,
我们在关于巴黎的那期节目中和阿涅斯·帕雷谈过这一点，那种罪犯和侦探在巴黎的下水道里以及（你知道的）宏伟的公寓里进行史诗般较量的氛围。这也是坡在创作他的侦探小说时所借鉴的背景，我想他写了三篇侦探故事，背景都设定在巴黎。那个侦探叫什么名字？是阿尔塞纳吗？是迪潘。迪潘西纳？是迪潘。迪潘，是的，就是迪潘。而坡很快就对那个失去了兴趣。你还有狄更斯，
who in Bleak House introduces Inspector Bucket. Yes. There are no great kind of mysteries or anything, but he's the kind of the prototype. I suppose he becomes Inspector Lestrade or Gregson, all the various inspectors that you get. Sergeant Cuff in the Moonstone. Yeah, in Wilkie Collins.
他在《荒凉山庄》中引入了巴克特督察。是的。虽然没有什么重大的谜团之类，但他算是这种类型的原型。我想他后来演变成了雷斯特拉德探长或格雷格森，以及你在书中遇到的各种探长。《月亮宝石》中的库夫警长。是的，在威尔基·柯林斯的小书中。
And in Wilkie Collins' book, that does feel quite Holmesian because the threat is coming from India. From outside, isn't it? Which I think we're going to get into later on because I think this is a really fascinating aspect of the Holmes stories. But what Conan Doyle does is to take these kind of various semi-formed ideas for a literary tradition and just crystallizes it. And it's the figure of Holmes, clearly,
在威尔基·柯林斯书中，确实很有福尔摩斯的风范，因为威胁来自印度。来自外部，对吧？我想我们稍后会深入探讨这一点，因为我觉得这是福尔摩斯故事中一个非常迷人的方面。但柯南·道尔所做的，是将这些半成熟的文学传统构想浓缩并定型。这显然归功于福尔摩斯这个人物，
because Holmes is also the embodiment of the idea that pure science can solve everything. And so the very word science has not been used in the sense that we use it now, commonly until kind of the middle of the 19th century. Yeah, because science just means kind of knowledge, right? Yeah. So as late as, I think, the second half of the 19th century, science in Oxford means the study of Aristotle, which is everything in a sense that Holmes is rejecting.
因为福尔摩斯也是“纯科学能够解决一切问题”这一理念的化身。因此，“科学”这个词在19世纪中叶之前，并没有像我们今天这样被普遍使用。是的，因为科学以前只意味着知识，对吧？是的。直到19世纪下半叶，在牛津大学，“科学”依然指的是对亚里士多德的研究，这在某种程度上与福尔摩斯所排斥的一切不谋而合。
And so you have... Knowledge of literature and philosophy nil, according to Watson. Although, very interested in history. So he writes apparently a monograph on early English charters. Oh, right. He's interested in linguistics. He writes a paper on the Chaldean roots of early Cornish. Yeah.
所以你有……根据华生的说法，文学和哲学知识为零。不过，他对历史非常感兴趣。显然，他写过一篇关于早期英国特许状的专著。哦，真的吗？他对语言学很感兴趣。他写过一篇关于早期康沃尔语中迦勒底语根源的论文。是的。
But of course, the papers that he famously writes are on cigarette ash. Yeah, toxins. Toxins. yeah but of course the papers that he famously writes are on cigarette ash yeah toxins toxins and on fingerprints which is also incredibly new science so developed in india in the the 1850s by the colonial authorities there and there are people in england who say well we should pick this up but it's rejected by scotland yard in 1886 which is you know that's the decade when chelock homes is starting to appear and so i think that that also is a crucial aspect, isn't it? It is that we've had a lot of people asking about this. Is Sherlock Holmes the first superhero? So that tradition of someone who is smarter, cleverer, more knowledgeable than the police and the conventional authorities.
当然，他那些名声大噪的论文主题是烟灰。是的，毒素。毒素。是的，但当然，他那些著名的论文是关于烟灰的，是的，毒素，毒素，还有指纹——这也是一项极其新颖的科学，是在19世纪50年代由那里的殖民地当局在印度开发的。英格兰当时也有人说：“我们应该采纳这个，”但苏格兰场在1886年拒绝了，你知道的，那正是歇洛克·福尔摩斯开始崭露头角的十年。所以我觉得这也是一个至关重要的方面，对吧？我们有很多听众问过这个问题：歇洛克·福尔摩斯是第一个超级英雄吗？也就是那种比警察和常规权力机构更聪明、更机智、知识更渊博的人物的传统。
And that's the key thing. That's why people come to him. You know, he's come to his rooms in Bakerstreet. So I think that's all part of it. But I think above all, it's the atmosphere of it, isn't it? I mean, it's the language, of Sherlock Holmes in 1933, which is kind of the first great study of Sherlock Holmes as a literary phenomenon. And he says of it that the 1880s are a smug and happy time, a time of prosperity and great contentment, which of course is deeply ironic because all kinds of terrible things are going on. But there is also, I think, that sense that Sherlock Holmes is the guardian angel of London at its imperial and cultural peak. Well, this is one of the fascinating things, that London is a world city in this period. It is clearly the world's great metropolis. And you get a massive sense of that in the Sherlock Holmes stories.
而这才是关键所在。这也是人们来找他的原因。（你知道的）他来到贝克街的寓所。所以我觉得这些都是其中的一部分。但最重要的是，那种氛围，不是吗？我是说，这种语言，正如1933年的……他是将歇洛克·福尔摩斯作为文学现象进行研究的首批大师之一。他这样评价那个时代：18世纪80年代是一个自满而快乐的时代，一个繁荣且极度满足的时代，当然这充满了极大的讽刺，因为当时正发生着各种可怕的事情。但我也认为，有一种感觉，即歇洛克·福尔摩斯是伦敦在其帝国和文化巅峰时期的守护神。嗯，这是一个令人着迷的事实：伦敦在这一时期是一座世界级城市。它显然是世界上最伟大的大都市。你在歇洛克·福尔摩斯的故事中能强烈地感受到这一点。
But just before we come back to London, this thing about Holmes as a superhero, we had an enormous number of questions about this. So Ian, Elvis717, who basically bombarded us with questions. One of them is, he says, why does Holmes still resonate today? The use of science to solve crime,
不过在我们回到伦敦之前，关于福尔摩斯作为超级英雄这一点，我们收到了数量惊人的提问。比如伊恩，也就是Elvis717，他基本上用问题把我们轰炸了一番。其中一个问题是：“为什么福尔摩斯至今仍能引起共鸣？用科学来破案，
does that make him the original superhero? So the superhero is really the superhero is developed a few decades later in america um a character who appears to be normal but has powers right and and not necessarily batman doesn't well batman doesn't have superpowers batman i guess is the closest and i think that there are kind of Batman-Sherlock Holmes crossovers. But just before America, there is also, and this is quite topical, Maurice LeBlanc writes a character called Lupin, who is a kind of thief.
这是否让他成为最初的超级英雄？”所以超级英雄这个概念实际上是在几十年后在美国发展起来的——一个看起来很普通但拥有超能力的的角色，对吧？而且不一定，蝙蝠侠并不——好吧，蝙蝠侠没有超能力，蝙蝠侠我猜是最接近的，而且我认为存在某种蝙蝠侠与歇洛克·福尔摩斯的跨界联动。但在美国出现之前，还有——这相当具有时代话题性——莫里斯·勒布朗创作了一个名叫鲁邦的角色，他是一个某种意义上的小偷。
He's a gentleman burglar. And he, so Lupin crosses swords with Sherlock Holmes. And Conan Doyle complained about this, that it was kind of copyright infringement. Oh, they rip off Holmes and put him in the books? Okay. So LeBlanc calls him Herlock Sholmes and Dr. Wilson. Brilliant. No one would guess it.
他是个绅士大盗。他与歇洛克·福尔摩斯交过手。柯南·道尔对此曾抱怨过，认为这属于侵权。哦，他们抄袭了福尔摩斯，把他放进书里？好吧。所以勒布朗管他叫“赫洛克·肖姆斯”（Herlock Sholmes）和“威尔逊医生”（Dr. Wilson）。太妙了。没人能猜得出来。
And they kind of cross swords and develop a kind of respectful admiration for each other. And in a way, it's rather like Umberto Eco's tribute to the English character in William of Baskerville in The Name of the Rose, which is modelled on Sherlock Holmes. In a way, the portrayal of Sherlock Holmes, Herlock Shames in Lupin, is, I think, one of the great French tributes
他们交手过，并对彼此产生了某种充满敬意的钦佩。某种程度上，这很像翁贝托·エコ在《玫瑰的名字》中对威廉·德·巴斯克维尔这一英国人物的致敬，而后者的原型就是歇洛克·福尔摩斯。从某种意义上说，在鲁邦中对歇洛克·福尔摩斯（赫洛克·肖姆斯）的塑造，我认为是法国对英国及英国性格的最伟大致敬之一。而且很有意思的是，显然我们有了更新版本的歇洛克·福尔摩斯，
to England and to English character. And it's kind of really telling that, obviously, we've had the updated version of Sherlock Holmes. Benedict Cumberbatch. But the French equivalent of that is Lupin, which is kind of also running at the moment both both i think fantastic um so there is that sense again that the the there's a kind of the
也就是本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇的版本。但法国的同类作品就是《鲁邦》，目前这两个版本似乎都在热播——我觉得都很棒。所以那种感觉依然存在，即伦敦和巴黎之间存在着一种
interconnection between london and paris the um the great detective the great burglar the great robber um and and then yeah that tradition migrates to america where it becomes much more vital um let's talk a bit about... So Holmes is a very patrician figure, isn't he? So he and Watson are both upper middle class, I suppose, aren't they? Watson has been to Afghanistan and come back with a war wound, wants to take rooms, and he's recommended... Somebody says there's this very strange fellow
互联互通，伟大侦探、伟大江洋大盗、伟大劫匪……然后，这种传统迁移到了美国，在那里变得更有活力。我们来聊聊……所以福尔摩斯是一个非常具有贵族气派的人物，对吧？所以他和华生都是上中产阶级，我想，对吧？华生去过阿富汗，带着战争创伤回来，想找个地方合租，然后有人向他推荐……有人说有个非常古怪的家伙，
that you might get on well with him. Why don't you go and and he gets there and homes homes is rich you know he has expensive habits obviously the cocaine um all his instruments and stuff he charges astronomical fees to for well consultancies because he doesn't always charge but no he's a robin hood figure yeah there is mention of when the fees are mentioned they're very large and very rich people. He takes large feeds from people who can afford it. Exactly. So that he can then afford to take on cases for people who can't afford it.
你可能会和他处得来。你为什么不去找他呢？他到了那里，发现福尔摩斯很有钱（你知道的），他有昂贵的嗜好，显然包括可卡因，还有他所有的仪器设备。他为咨询收取天价费用，因为他并不总是免费服务的——不，他是个罗宾汉式的人物。是的，提到咨询费时，金额都非常庞大，而且都是向非常有钱的人收取的。他向付得起钱的人收取巨额费用。
But I suppose what he exudes, what both of these men exude, what international audiences at the time would recognise as a kind of stereotypical Britishness or Englishness, wouldn't they? I mean, these are precisely the kind of mad dogs and Englishmen who would eat beef steaks for breakfast in in india or something at the time well they i mean there's a lot about their breakfast yeah you know they they're always they i think they get up late and have rashers they do they have colossal very meaty breakfasts yes and then kind of ladies and veils turn up exactly i
这样他就能负担得起为那些付不起钱的人接案子了。不过我猜他所散发出的气质——这两个人所散发出的、当时国际读者一眼就能认出的那种典型的英国性或英格兰性，对吧？我的意思是，这正是那种“疯狂的狗和英国人”的真实写照，他们当时在印度或其他地方的早餐还要吃牛排。嗯，他们——我的意思是，关于他们的早餐有很多描写，对吧？（你知道的）他们总是——我想他们起得很晚，吃熏肉，他们确实吃得很丰盛，充满肉类的早餐。是的，然后就会有戴面纱的女士出现。完全如此。
think that that um for decades after that tourists to tourists to London would expect it to be swathed in fog and to have rashers and bacon and eggs for breakfast. Well, actually, another character who's defined by his breakfasts, who's, I think, one of the literary descendants of Sherlock Holmes is James Bond. Ian Fleming describes in great detail how Bond's housekeeper gives him the right jam the right eggs boiled to the right temperature I mean this is very very Holmesian kind of behavior and the sort of setup in Bond's flat I mean there's no Dr Watson because I think it's I think it's almost impossible for any any English writer not to do breakfasts not not to be influenced by that legacy yeah I mean it's
我觉得……在接下来的几十年里，去伦敦的游客都会期待那里被雾气笼罩，早餐吃着熏肉和鸡蛋。事实上，另一个以早餐闻名的角色——我认为他是歇洛克·福尔摩斯的文学传人之一——就是詹姆斯·邦德。伊恩·弗莱明详细描述了邦德的管家如何为他准备正确的果酱、煮到刚好熟度的鸡蛋。我的意思是，这是一种非常非常福尔摩斯式的行为，还有邦德公寓里的陈设。我的意思是，这里没有华生医生，因为我觉得，任何英国作家都很难不写早餐，很难不受这种传统的深刻影响。是的，我的意思是，
you know so so both Bond and smiley are recognizably influenced by by the by the home stories i think that's absolutely right i think something that we should definitely talk about is empire this is the heyday of the british empire and funny so um i i have to be careful not to keep mentioning him on these on these podcasts but my son is really into sherlock hol Holmes and we watched all the Jeremy Brett Granada adaptations um which are brilliant and we listened to Stephen Fry a friend of the show um doing reading um the stories as an audiobook on the way to and from school and my son said to me god it's you know he didn't say god because he's sort of eight, but he said it's extraordinary how India is mentioned all the time.
你知道的，所以无论是邦德还是史迈利，都明显受到了福尔摩斯故事的影响。我认为这绝对是正确的。我认为我们绝对应该谈论的一个话题是帝国。这是大英帝国的全盛时期，有趣的是……嗯，我得小心别在这些播客里一直提起他，但我儿子非常喜欢歇洛克·福尔摩斯，我们看完了杰瑞米·布雷主演的格拉纳达电视台的所有改编剧——它们棒极了——而且我们在上下学路上还听了节目老朋友斯蒂芬·弗雷朗读的有声书。我儿子对我说：“天哪，这（他没说天哪，因为他大概八岁），这太不可思议了，印度竟然无处不在。”
There are always characters coming back from abroad. Including Dr. Watson. Yeah, Dr. Watson's come back from Afghanistan, hasn't he? Or the Northwest Front. Yeah, he has. And he's, yes, badly wounded. And so there is that sense that if you go to India or to the Empire, you're going to come back and you're going to be wounded and you're going to bring danger.
总是有角色从海外归来。包括华生医生。是的，华生医生从阿富汗回来了，对吧？或者西北边境。是的，他确实回来了。而且他，是的，受了重伤。所以有一种感觉：如果你去印度或帝国其他地方，你就会带着伤归来，并带来危险。
That's it. So there is that sense. I mean, famously, the description of London is that it's that great cesspool into which all the loungers and idlers of the Empire are irresistibly drained. Yes. But there is also, I mean, yeah, so the sign of four. I mean, you were going to say that's the classic example. So the Indian mutiny is in the background. The Indian mutiny is part of the backstory.
就是这样。所以确实有这种感觉。我的意思是，最著名的对伦敦的描述是，它是那个巨大的阴沟，帝国的游手好闲者和懒汉们不可抗拒地被排入其中。是的。但也有，我的意思是，是的，比如《四签名》。我的意思是，你本来想说那是经典例子。所以印度民族起义是背景。印度民族起义是背景故事的一部分。
There's a character called Major Sholto. I mean, I don't want to give the plot away for people who might be inspired to read Sherlock Holmes, but there's basically treasure that has been stolen during the Indian mutiny. And one of the key figures is a man called Jonathan Small, who has one leg, who is in the third buffs and ends up at the Agra Fort.
有一个角色叫肖尔托少校。我的意思是，我不想把剧情剧透给那些可能被激发去读歇洛克·福尔摩斯的人，但基本上有一批在印度民族起义期间被盗的宝藏。其中一个关键人物是一个叫乔纳森·小的人，他只有一条腿，曾在第三步兵团服役，最后到了阿格拉堡。
And then he ends up on the Andaman Islands and he has a friend called Tonga. And they come to... And that, I mean, if you're a sort of historian who likes kind of post-colonial jargon, I mean, you can have a field day with this kind of stuff. That, you know, there's the sort of guilt of empire and there's importing the violence and the cruelty and all of this sort of guilt of empire and there's importing the violence and the cruelty
然后他流落到了安达曼群岛，他有一个朋友叫汤加。他们来到了……而这个——如果你是一个喜欢后殖民主义术语的历史学家，我的意思是，你简直可以对此大做文章。也就是帝国负罪感，把暴力、残酷以及
and all of this sort of stuff from the imperial periphery back into the metropolis. And that happens again and again in these stories, actually, that somebody has been to India or thereabouts and has been driven mad or has committed some hideous crime or there's some ghastly secret, and then they bring it back into London or they bring it back into kind of middle class suburbia. Yeah. So actually, one of the very best, most frightening Sherlock Holmes short stories, The Speckled Band.
所有这些来自帝国边缘的暴力和残酷重新输入到大都市中。而这种情节在这些故事中一再上演：某人去过印度或其周边地区，结果精神失常或犯下了可怕的罪行，或者隐藏着某种可怕的秘密，然后他们把这些带回了伦敦，或者带回了中产阶级的郊区。是的。事实上，其中一个最好、最令人毛骨悚然的歇洛克·福尔摩斯短篇小说就是《斑点带子》。
And again, I don't want to give away plot, but it involves, I think, an Indian swamp adder, which isn't good news for anyone involved. And there is that sense the the empire risks blowback basically so and again i think i think that that part of the appeal of of homes for english readers the original english readers again rather like kind of the figure of batman standing proof against you know the the darkness that's bred in gotham city is that, is that he's kind of like a guardian angel who can stand proof against the menace of the outside. And also, of course, there's quite a bit of American stuff as well.
同样，我不想剧透，但它涉及一条印度的沼泽蝰蛇，这对涉事的所有人来说都不是什么好消息。所以有一种感觉，即帝国面临着反噬的风险。所以再次我认为，福尔摩斯对英国读者（最初的英国读者）的吸引力的一部分——同样有点像蝙蝠侠挺身而出对抗哥谭市孕育的黑暗——在于他就像一个守护神，能够抵御来自外部的威胁。当然，其中也有相当一部分美国元素。
So the Valley of Fear, which has kind of Pinkertons and Strikers and all that Andrew Carnegie stuff going on in America. So there is this sense in which, although Holmes is a very English figure, everything from around the world is coming here. My two favourite examples of those things you've talked about are one. So with India, you mentioned the Speckle Band. So there's a character in Speckle Band called Dr. Grimesby Roylott. What a brilliant name. And he's been in Calcutta.
比如《恐怖谷》，里面涉及了美国的平克顿侦探社、罢工者以及安德鲁·卡耐基式的背景。因此，尽管福尔摩斯是一个非常英国本土的形象，但来自世界各地的一切都在向这里汇聚。关于你刚才提到的那些事情，我最喜欢的两个例子是：第一，关于印度，你提到了《斑点带子》。《斑点带子》里有一个角色叫格赖姆斯比·罗伊洛特医生。多棒的名字啊。他在加尔各答待过。
And you kind of know something weird is going to happen because he's brought back a baboon and a cheetah which are roaming around they're roaming around outside his house and he's also made friends with a lot of gypsies which in in sort of readers of Enneablighton will know is never a good sign no well that's very the moon that's very the moonstone isn't it because that's kind of Wilkie in Wilkie Collins there are these itinerant Indian fakirs or something and you know that they bring doom, but also they relate to something that's happened out in the Empire. And my favourite American thing is, very strange actually,
你隐约觉得会有怪事发生，因为他带回了一只狒狒和一只猎豹，它们在他的房子外面四处游荡，而且他还跟许多吉普赛人交了朋友——熟悉伊妮德·布莱顿作品的读者会知道，这绝不是什么好兆头。不，这很像《月亮宝石》，对吧？因为那有点像威尔基·柯林斯风格，里面有那些流浪的印度苦行僧之类的人，你知道他们会带来厄运，而且他们与发生在帝国远疆的事情有关。而我最喜欢的美国元素，非常奇怪的是，
the Five Orange Pips. That's basically a story about the KKK. So the first iteration of Ku Klux Klan has gone, but they basically pitch up in England to seek revenge on somebody who has betrayed them. And I guess what that gives you is exactly what you were saying, that the sense that the stories are happening
《五个橘核》。那基本上是一个关于三K党的。所以第一代三K党已经消亡了，但他们基本上跑到英格兰来向一个背叛过他们的人寻仇。我想这带给你的正是你刚才所说的：这些故事发生在一个庞大网络的中心，而且事实上柯南·道尔的读者可能并不一定都是英国人。我的意思是，他们可能是美国人、澳大利亚人什么的，他们可能
at the centre of a massive network, and that actually Conan Doyle is writing for people who may not automatically be British. I mean, they may be American or Australian or something, and they may, you know have this sense of travel, but also travel is something that's quite unsettling. Yes. So, I mean, as a kind of source for historians,
对旅行有这种切身体会，但旅行也是一件相当令人不安的事。所以，作为历史学家的资料来源，
Holmes is fascinating on the relationship of the metropolis to the imperial peripheries. Yeah. Fascinating on the evolution of the relationship between Britain and America, because America is a kind of running theme throughout. But also, what we've talked about quite a lot, the build up to the First World War, because plans for submarines and battleships and so on are always being pilfered, and Holmes is always having to get it back. And in the kind of the wonderful sense of depth that
福尔摩斯在探讨大都市与帝国边缘的关系方面令人着迷。是的。在研究英国与美国关系演变方面令人着迷，因为美国是贯穿始终的主题。而且，正如我们经常讨论的，它还反映了第一次世界大战前的蓄势阶段，因为潜水舰和战舰的图纸等机密总是被盗窃，福尔摩斯总是不得不把它们夺回来。在那种福尔摩斯角色所独有的、奇妙的深度感中，
you get with Holmes's character, lots being unsaid. There are kind of allusions to how he's been employed by the Dutch royal family to sort things out for them and that kind of thing. We've got a question from Dr. Crom, great classicist. Which Holmes case that is merely alluded to would be the best to exist as a full version by Conan Doyle himself? For me, it still has to be the giant rat of Sumatra, as mentioned in the adventure of the Sussex vampire. And the giant rat of Sumatra famously is the one, the tale for which the world is not yet ready.
有许多话没有明说。其中暗示了他曾受雇于荷兰王室为他们解决问题之类的事情。我们收到了来自伟大的古典学者克罗姆医生的提问：“在福尔摩斯的案件中，有哪些仅被提及、最适合由柯南·道尔本人写成完整版？”对我来说，依然是《苏门答腊巨鼠》，正如《苏塞克斯吸血鬼》中所提及的那样。苏门答腊巨鼠大名鼎鼎，就是那个“世界尚未做好准备迎接”的故事。
But there's also one involving a trained cormorant, which I think would be brilliant. And there's the strange case of Isadora Passano, who was found stark staring mad with a matchbox in front of him, which contained a remarkable worm said to be unknown to science. So that's, I mean, that's part of the fun as well, isn't it? It is, yeah. Yeah, exactly.
此外还有一个涉及训练有素的鸬鹚的案子，我觉得那也会非常精彩。还有伊莎多拉·帕萨诺的离奇案件，她被发现时目光呆滞、双眼圆睁，面前放着一个火柴盒，里面装着一条据称科学界未知的奇特蠕虫。所以，这也是乐趣的一部分，不是吗？是的，确实如此。是的，没错。
He works for the Prime Minister, I think, at one point, doesn't he? There's the naval treaty that goes missing. And then obviously in his last bow, at the end, there's a brilliant quote. Actually, I was going to read this because I thought it's so First World War. So at the end of his last bow, Holmes says to Watson, Good old Watson, you are the one fixed point in a changing age. There is an east wind coming all the same. Such a wind has never blew on
他甚至还为首相工作过，我想，有一次海军条约失踪了。然后显然在《最后一鞠躬》的结尾，有一句精彩的台词。事实上，我本来打算读一下这段，因为我觉得它太有第一次世界大战的风格了。所以在《最后一鞠躬》的结尾，福尔摩斯对华生说：“老华生，在这样一个瞬息万变的时代里，你是唯一的定海神针。东风依然会吹来。
England yet. It will be cold and bitter Watson, and a good many of us may wither before its blast. But, and this you see Conan Doyle's kind of jingoism. Conan Doyle says, but it's God's own wind nonetheless, and a cleaner, better, stronger land will lie in the sunshine when the storm has cleared
从来没有哪股风曾这样吹拂过英格兰。它将是寒冷而刺骨的，华生，我们当中有许多人可能会在它的狂飙下枯萎。但是——在这里你可以看到柯南·道尔式的沙文主义。柯南·道尔说——但它毕竟是上帝之风，当风暴过去后，阳光下将会展现一片更洁净、更好、更强大的土地。”
i might have that read at my funeral actually i think that would be i love that in mind i'll bear that but also a bit he um holmes gets given an emerald um tie pin by queen victoria does he yes he he um he foils the plot to steal the Bruce Partington. The plans for the Bruce Partington submarine. So it's incredibly interesting as a mirror held up to all the paranoias and the complexities and the ambivalences and the ambiguities of Britain's global role at the end of the 19th century. So I think that provides justification enough for talking about homes. Do you think we should have a break now? And perhaps when we come back,
我甚至想让这段话在我葬礼上被朗读，我觉得这太……我很喜欢这段，我会记住的。还有，维多利亚女王曾送给福尔摩斯一枚祖母绿领带夹，对吧？是的，他挫败了一起企图盗窃布鲁斯·帕廷顿计划的阴谋。布鲁斯·帕廷顿潜艇的设计图。因此，作为一面折射出19世纪末英国全球角色的种种偏执、复杂性、矛盾与暧昧的镜子，它具有极其重要的价值。所以我认为，这已经足以构成我们谈论福尔摩斯的理由了。你觉得我们现在该休息一下了吗？等我们回来后，
have a look at Conan Doyle himself? Sure, that's a great plan. All right, see you after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip.
也许可以聊聊柯南·道尔本人？当然，这主意不错。好的，休息过后见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料。
And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. welcome back to the rest is history you know our methods by now uh tom holland we're talking about sherlock holmes and you have a question i believe or do you want me to ask the question why don't you i think you want to answer it so andrew lysett who i believe is a a henchman or crony of yours well he's a biographer of conan doyle he knows far more about this than we do but he's a cricketing person isn't he he plays in the authors the team i play for which for which conan doyle
在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉大家这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果您想享受无广告收听、独家加更节目以及抢先购买现场活动门票的福利，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史其余部分》（The Rest is History），大家现在对我们的套路已经很熟悉了，呃，汤姆·霍兰德，我们正在聊福尔摩斯，我记得你有一个问题，还是你想让我来问？你来问吧，我想你很想回答。所以安德鲁·莱赛特（Andrew Lycett），我坚信他是你的一个爪牙或死党，好吧，他是柯南·道尔的传记作家，他对这方面的了解远多于我们，但他是个板球迷，对吧？他效力于“作家队”，也就是我效力的那支球队，而柯南·道尔正是该队的创始人之一。
was a founding member yeah i knew you'd want to mention that so he asks or he what he asks i mean he knows the answer he asks about the origin of the name sherlock holmes in his opinion the idea that he was called after two nottinghamshire cricketers was always far-fetched although his creator was known for his cricketing feats, he claimed the wicket of WG Grace, and he played for one or two interesting teams. He's talking about his own team. He did.
——是的，我就知道你会想提这一点。所以他问——或者说他问的，我的意思是他是知道答案的——他询问了福尔摩斯这个名字的起源。在他看来，福尔摩斯这个名字取自两个诺丁汉郡板球员的说法一直都很牵强，尽管他的创作者以其板球绝技而闻名，他曾三振出局过W·G·格雷斯（WG Grace），并且他还为一两支有趣的球队效力过。他是在说他自己的球队。他确实效力过。
So talk to us about all this. Talk to us about Sherlock Holmes' names, and then I'll allow you on Cricket. So the theory that Sherlock Holmes derives from two Nottinghamshire cricketers. So there was the wicket-keeper, Mordecai Sherwin, and there was a fast bowler, Frank Shacklock. So that's the theory. I mean, I don't think it's convincing.
所以，跟我们聊聊这一切吧。跟我们聊聊福尔摩斯名字的由来，然后我就允许你讲板球。所以，关于福尔摩斯源于两名诺丁汉郡板球员的理论，其中一个是守门员莫代凯·舍温（Mordecai Sherwin），另一个是快球手弗兰克·夏克洛克（Frank Shacklock）。这就是那个理论。我的意思是，我觉得这并不令人信服。
Sherwin and Shacklock, and you get Sherlock Holmes. Yeah. Except that when Shacklock then moved to play for Derbyshire, where his fellow fast bowler was called William Mycroft. Oh, right. Mycroft is... Yeah William Mycroft. Oh, right. Mycroft is... Yeah, Mycroft is Holmes' brother. Holmes' brother.
舍温和夏克洛克，然后就成了福尔摩斯。是的。不过当夏克洛克后来转会去德比郡效力时，他那里的搭档快球手名叫威廉·迈克罗夫特（William Mycroft）。哦，对的。迈克罗夫特是……对，迈克罗夫特是福尔摩斯的哥哥。福尔摩斯的哥哥。
So that's... Who knows? But I think it's likelier. I think... I mean, Conan Doyle had various relatives. So there was some relation of his aunt or something. Had been... Was called Sherlock, I think, or something like that. And there was someone he was at school with at Stoneyhurst
所以……谁知道呢？但我认为这种可能性更大。我觉得……我的意思是，柯南·道尔有很多亲戚。比如他姑妈的某个亲戚什么的，曾经……我记得就叫福尔摩斯（Sherlock），或者类似的名字。而且他在斯托尼赫斯特（Stoneyhurst）上学时，也有个同学叫福尔摩斯。
who was called Sherlock. Also at Stoneyhurst, there were two brothers called Moriarty. One of whom was called James. Yeah, but that's kind of unsurprising, though, because authors often use the names of, I mean, names they're familiar with, obviously. I think the interesting thing is how the Sherlock Holmes formula became a formula.
同样在斯托尼赫斯特，还有两兄弟叫莫里亚蒂（Moriarty）。其中一个叫詹姆斯。是的，但其实这也并不算出奇，因为作家经常会使用他们熟悉的名字，也就是他们显而易见很熟悉的名字。我觉得有趣的是，福尔摩斯的创作套路是如何成为一种公式的。
So if you look at other Edwardian or early 20th century detectives, the most famous one is Sexton Blake, which is clearly, I mean, Sexton Blake became the stuff of lots of kind of... Bulldog Drummond and all that. Well, Bulldog Drummond is more of a James Bond antecedent, and the name isn't quite as similar. But Sexton Blake is. I think we talked before, Sonny,
如果你看看其他爱德华时代或20世纪初的侦探，最著名的是塞克斯顿·布莱克（Sexton Blake），显然，我是说，塞克斯顿·布莱克成了很多……比如《布尔多格·德拉蒙德》（Bulldog Drummond）之类作品的素材。好吧，《布尔多格·德拉蒙德》更像是詹姆斯·邦德的前身，而且名字也没那么相似。但塞克斯顿·布莱克确实是。我想我们之前聊过，索尼，
I basically talk all the time about the Billy Bunter stories, the Greyfriars stories, very popular with boys and girls, I guess, in these years. And there's a detective in that who's the headmaster's brother who's called Ferrer's Log. And there's also the detective who fights Fu Manchu who's called Nayland Smith. So there's obviously this sort of pattern
我基本上无时无刻不在谈论比利·班特（Billy Bunter）的故事、格雷弗赖尔斯（Greyfriars）的故事，这些在当年非常受男孩和女孩们的欢迎，我想是的。里面有一个侦探是校长的主治医生——不对，是校长的兄弟，名叫费勒斯·洛格（Ferrer's Log）。还有一个与傅满洲（Fu Manchu）战斗的侦探名叫内兰·史密斯（Nayland Smith）。所以很明显存在这样一种模式：
that you have a two-syllable first name and then a one-syllable second name. And in the Anthony Buckridge Jennings stories, which are written... Have you ever heard of those, Tom? Jennings and Derbyshire? In the 1950s and 60s about schoolboys. They try to invent their own Sherlock Holmes-style detective.
即一个双音节的名字加上一个单音节的姓氏。在安东尼·巴克里奇（Anthony Buckridge）的詹宁斯（Jennings）系列故事中，这些故事是写给……你听说过那些吗，汤姆？《詹宁斯和德比郡》？讲述的是20世纪50和60年代的男校学生。他们试图发明他们自己的福尔摩斯风格的侦探。
And they write... The first name they come up with is Nehemiah Beltitude. And they agree that this is a terrible name for a detective. And the next name is Egbert Snope. And they agree that that's also... And they settle for Flickston Slick, which is, again again kind of two syllables then one syllable so that is interesting but i don't think it's the most interesting i
他们写道……他们想出的第一个名字是尼希米·贝尔蒂图德（Nehemiah Beltitude）。他们一致认为这是一个非常糟糕的侦探名字。下一个名字是埃格伯特·斯诺普（Egbert Snope）。他们也一致认为那同样……最终他们定下了“弗利克斯顿·斯利克”（Flickston Slick），这同样是前边双音节后边单音节的结构。所以这很有趣，但我认为它不是最有趣的点。
think it's very interesting i think you know i think the most interesting aspect is as uh andrew pointed out the link crickets i was trying to take you off that but but also more generally colin doyle was an incredibly active sportsman so he played almost every sport. Yeah. So he played cricket, played rugby, made Watson a rugby player. Yes. Played football. I think he played.
我觉得非常有趣，你知道，我觉得最有趣的方面正如……呃，安德鲁指出的那样，是与板球的联系。我刚才正试图把你从这个话题上拉开，但，但更广泛地说，柯南·道尔是一个极其活跃的运动员，他几乎玩过每一项运动。是的。所以他打板球、打橄榄球，把华生设定为一个橄榄球运动员。是的。踢足球。我想他踢过。
He played for Portsmouth. He did. Well, antecedent of Portsmouth or something. Yeah. So he helped set up the club there. He played golf and reputedly is one of the first people to play golf in America. He played with Kipling.
他曾为朴茨茅斯队踢过球。他确实踢过。好吧，那是朴茨茅斯队的前身还是什么的。是的。所以他协助建立那里的俱乐部。他打高尔夫球，据传是第一批在美国打高尔夫球的人之一。他曾和吉卜林一起打过。
I think lost to Kipling. Wow. Who knew Kipling was so good at golf? And he was an early adopter of skiing, an English, early British adopter of skiing. Well, obviously, he'd been to Switzerland, hadn't he? Yeah. Hence the right amount of folks. But really, it's the cricket for which he's chiefly known.
我想输给了吉卜林。哇。谁知道吉卜林高尔夫打得那么好？他还是滑雪的早期尝鲜者，是一个英国、英国最早的滑雪爱好者。嗯，很显然，他去过瑞士，不是吗？是的。因此去对了地方。不过真正让他闻名遐迩的还是板球。
And apparently he wasn't a bit like me. He was terrible at school. Right. Took it up and became a great player. So there's hope for you yet, Tom. Yeah. I've become a great player, Dominic. And his greatest feat, which Andrew alludes to in his question,
而且显然他一点也不像我。他在学校时板球打得极烂。对的。后来才捡起来并成为了一名伟大的球员。所以汤姆，你还有希望。对的。我已经成为了一名伟大的球员了，多米尼克。他最伟大的壮举，也就是安德鲁在问题中提到的，
is that he got the wicket of WG Grace and Grace was I mean for American or or non-British listeners probably the most famous Englishman yeah an absolutely titanic figure I mean massive massive large in the way that Conan Doyle was large or Nigel Bruce in the Basil Rathbone adaptations massive great beard um colossal figure and so to get him out was the greatest thing that any critic would want um and uh he had scored a century by the time that Conan Doyle got him out um but Conan Doyle still celebrated and um in a in an earlier podcast the the one about the uh Ukraine I quoted Tennyson I'm now going to quote Conan Doyle's poetry.
就是他三振出局了W·G·格雷斯，而格雷斯——我的意思是，对于美国或非英国听众来说——可能是最著名的英国人了，绝对是一个泰坦式的人物。我的意思是，他的体型巨大，就像柯南·道尔那样魁梧，或者像巴斯尔·拉瑟本（Basil Rathbone）改编版里的奈杰尔·布鲁斯（Nigel Bruce）一样庞大。他留着大胡子，是个庞然大物。所以能三振出局他，是任何板球手梦寐以求的最高成就，而且……当柯南·道尔将他三振出局时，他已经拿下一百分了。但柯南·道尔仍然为此庆祝，并且……在之前的某一期播客中，也就是关于……呃乌克兰的那期，我引用了丁尼生（Tennyson）的诗，现在我要引用柯南·道尔的诗。
And this is him writing about W.G. Grace. Before me, he stands like a vision, bearded and burly and brown, a smile of good humor derision as he waits for the first to come down with the beard of a goth or a vandal, his bat hanging ready and free, his great hairy hands on the handle, and his menacing eyes upon me. Oh, that's very good. Magnificent stuff. Although his great hairy hands, that's not the nicest image. Okay, so Conan Doyle. Now, Conan Doyle is an absolutely 24-carat fascinating man.
这是他写W·G·格雷斯的诗句：“他立于我面前，宛如幻影，留着胡须，魁梧而又黝黑，带着幽默与嘲讽的微笑，等待着第一球飞向地面，带着哥特人或汪达尔人般的胡须，球拍垂下随时准备挥舞，他毛茸茸的大手握着球柄，充满威胁的目光注视着我。”哦，这写得太好了。宏伟壮丽的诗句。虽然“他毛茸茸的大手”听起来不是最美好的意象。好吧，这就是柯南·道尔。现在，柯南·道尔是一个绝对纯度百分之百、引人入胜的奇男子。
He was the judge, Tom. Did you know this? He was the judge in the world's first ever bodybuilding contest. Well, there's a sport again, you see, isn't there? I didn't know that, but I'm not surprised to learn it. He stood twice for Parliament as a liberal unionist. So, in other words, that's the sort of very much the imperialist kind of wing of the liberal family, hence the Boer War. He's obviously become very well known now because of the Adelge case.
他当过裁判，汤姆。你知道这件事吗？他是世界上第一场健美比赛的裁判。好吧，你看，这又是一项运动，对吧？我以前不知道，但我听到并不觉得奇怪。他曾两次以自由党联合派身份竞选议会席位。也就是说，那是自由党阵营中非常强烈的帝国主义派别，因此才有了布尔战争。由于阿达尔吉案（Adelge case），他现在显然变得非常著名了。
So these are kind of the great wily outrages, as they were known. In, I think, 1906, there was one of the very first Indian vicars in the Church of England. He was a Parsi, wasn't he? Yeah, he was a Parsi. Julian Barnes wrote a novel about it. A brilliant novel, Arthur and George. And his son, George, was falsely accused of these maimings of animals in a village near sort of just northern Wolverhampton.
这些案子也就是所谓的重大阴谋残害案。我记得在1906年，英国国教中出现了首批印度籍牧师之一。他是个帕西人（Parsi），对吧？是的，他是个帕西人。朱利安·巴恩斯（Julian Barnes）为此写过一部小说。一部精彩绝伦的小说，《亚瑟与乔治》（Arthur and George）。他的儿子乔治被诬告在伍尔弗汉普顿（Wolverhampton）北部某个村庄里残害动物。
Now, is that before or after Silver Blaze? I think it's after, actually, but I might be wrong. Contains the famous passage, which is incredibly useful for historians always to bear in mind, about the dog that doesn't bark in the night. Yes. The curious incident of the dog in the night. It's actually 14 years after I've just looked it up. So Conan Doyle obviously was remarkably prescient.
那么，这发生在《银斑马》（Silver Blaze）之前还是之后？我想实际上是在之后，不过我也可能记错。其中包含那个著名的段落，对于历史学家来说，永远铭记这一点极为有用，那就是关于夜里没有叫的狗的那段。是的。夜犬奇案。我刚查了一下，实际上是在14年之后。所以柯南·道尔显然具有非凡的先见之明。
Yes. The curious thing is that the dog doesn't bark. And of course, for historians, you're right. How many of us have used that yeah you know that um as the the thing that didn't happen is the really interesting thing and the other one is um it is a capital mistake my dear watson to theorize before one has the facts that's very good well that's a lesson to us all isn't it um but i suppose let's put aside conan door amateur detective because he gets george
是的。奇怪的是狗没有叫。当然，对于历史学家来说，你是对的。我们当中有多少人曾用过这个……呃，你知道的，把“没有发生的事情”作为真正有趣的事情。另一个是……“我亲爱的华生，在掌握事实之前就盲目进行理论推导，这是一个重大的错误。”这说得太好了。好吧，这对我们所有人都是一个教训，不是吗？嗯，不过我想，我们还是先把柯南·道尔这位业余侦探放一边吧，因为他把乔治
off effectively. He does, but there's another one as well. There's Oscar Slater. Do you know about him? I saw that. I know very vaguely, but you probably know far more about it than I do.
有效地解救了出来。他确实做到了，但还有另一个案子。还有奥斯卡·斯莱特（Oscar Slater）。你知道他吗？我看到过。我只是模模糊糊地知道，但你可能比我了解得多的多。
So, so Oscar, so, so just as George Adalge was a Parsi and therefore subject to prejudice from the police, which Conan Doyle was very, very clear about. Oscar Slater was a German Jew. And there is, this is in Glasgow.
所以，所以奥斯卡——所以，就像乔治·阿达尔吉是个帕西人，因此遭到警方偏见对待一样，柯南·道尔对此看得非常非常清楚。奥斯卡·斯莱特是个德国犹太人。当时是在格拉斯哥。
An old woman gets murdered. Her jewels get stolen. And Slater gets accused of it because he's pawned a jewel, which is not from the jewels that have been stolen from this murdered woman. But the police, basically, because he's a German Jew, finger him for it. And he crosses America, gets arrested when he lands in New York, gets sent back to Glasgow, gets convicted.
一个老妇人被谋杀。她的珠宝被盗。斯莱特被指控犯下了此案，因为他当当了一件珠宝，而这件珠宝并不是从那个被谋杀的老妇人那里偷来的珠宝。但警察基本上是因为他是个德国犹太人，就把罪名扣在了他头上。他横渡美国，在纽约登陆时被捕，被遣返回格拉斯哥，并被定罪。
And Conan Doyle leads the campaign to get him free. And it takes a very, very long time before he is. When he finally gets released, Conan Doyle has put up some money, basically, to pay for the retrial and is then outraged because Slater doesn't pay him back. And so Conan Doyle said of Slater that he is not a murderer, but an ungrateful dog. Well, I suppose you'd take that, wouldn't you? I mean, if you're out and you're free.
然后柯南·道尔领导了为他洗脱罪名的运动。这花了非常非常长的时间才得以实现。当他最终获释时，柯南·道尔基本上出资支付了重审费用，结果却感到愤怒，因为斯莱特没有还钱给他。所以柯南·道尔对斯莱特评价说，他不是个杀人犯，而是个忘恩负义的狗东西。好吧，我想你也会接受这个结果的，不是吗？我的意思是，如果你出狱重获自由的话。
You probably would um you probably but i mean those two miscarriages of justice i think are really interesting because we've slightly cast conan doyle as a um you know he's he's clearly an enthusiast for empire but he's also a man who's evidently very very sensitive and alert to miscarriages of justice and racially based miscarriages of justice yeah i think that's absolutely right i think um a very interesting i think it's easy to paint con Doyle as a comic figure. And actually, we shouldn't do that. Although that said, the one thing that most people know about Conan Doyle, apart from Sherlock Holmes, is the fairies and seances and all of this carry on, which has allowed people to perceive him as a comic figure.
你可能确实会……你可能会，但我的意思是，这两起冤假错案我认为真的非常有趣，因为我们此前把柯南·道尔塑造成了一个……你知道的，他显然是帝国主义的热情支持者，但同时他也是一个对冤假错案以及基于种族的冤假错案极其敏感、高度警觉的人。是的，我认为完全正确，我觉得……一个非常有趣的现象是，人们很容易把柯南·道尔描绘成一个喜剧人物。实际上，我们不应该这样做。话虽如此，除了福尔摩斯之外，人们对柯南·道尔最了解的一点，就是关于仙子、降神会以及所有这些折腾，正是这些让人们把他视为一个喜剧人物。
So I imagine you've got lots to say about that, because religion is your department, isn't it? Yeah, well well so lots of people have asked questions about um how how do we square the creation of sherlock holmes this arch rationalist with conan doyle's kind of increasingly public enthusiasm for spiritualism and i think it's clear that that spiritualism fills a void for people in the late vict, early 20th century. People who've lost their religious faith, but want to have some sense that there's an afterlife and some sense of communion with those who've died.
所以我想你对这方面一定有很多要说的，因为宗教是你的领域，对吧？是的，好吧，好吧——所以很多人都问过关于……呃，我们如何将福尔摩斯这个大理性主义者的创造，与柯南·道尔对灵媒主义日益公开的热情调和起来？我认为很显然，灵媒主义填补了19世纪末20世纪初人们内心的某种虚空。那些失去了宗教信仰，但又想在某种程度上相信有来世、并希望能与逝者交流的人。
Well, it's exactly what Roger Clark was saying. Yeah. What did he say? It was a, a decayed form of religion in a secular age or something like that. I can't remember. I'm misquoting him,
这正是罗杰·克拉克（Roger Clark）所说的。是的。他说什么来着？这是一种……世俗时代中退化的宗教形式，诸如此类。我不记得原话了。我引用得不太准确，
but Conan Doyle loses his faith as when he's at school. Yeah. He's gone to Stonyhurst Catholic school. It's in the aftermath of that, that he creates Holmes. And Holmes is a, is a, is a figure in whom you are Watson.
但柯南·道尔在上学时就失去了信仰。是的。他当时在斯托尼赫斯特天主教学校就读。正是在那之后不久，他创造了福尔摩斯。福尔摩斯是一个……你就是华生。
He constantly tells Watson to have faith in him. And Holmes has powers. His power of deduction is almost superhuman, isn't it? And Holmes has, Holmesism, an almost inhuman figure. He's a kind of, you could imagine him as a kind of religious ascetic or something. Well, I think, so Conan Doyle is writing, creates the figure of Holmes in the 1880s.
他不断告诉华生要对信任他。福尔摩斯拥有超凡的能力。他的推理能力几乎是超人的，对不对？福尔摩斯有一种……福尔摩斯主义，一个近乎非人的形象。他有点像……你可以把他想象成某种宗教苦行僧之类的人物。好吧，我认为——所以柯南·道尔在19世纪80年代写作并创造了福尔摩斯这个形象。
And that's the same period, I think, 85, 86, maybe 86, I think, when he starts to develop an interest in spiritualism. And in a sense, I guess it's kind of two aspects of the faith that he's abandoned. There's the faith that the church provides frameworks that if you put your faith in it, then it explains everything. And that's the role that Holmes serves. But it also provides the hope of life after death. And that's what the interest in spiritualism does. And it obviously then becomes turbocharged by the First World War, as it does for many, many people.
我认为那也是同一时期，85年、86年，也许是86年左右，他开始对灵媒主义产生兴趣。从某种意义上说，我想这可以说是他所放弃的信仰的两个方面。一方面是教会提供的信仰框架，只要你把信仰寄托于它，它就能解释一切，这就是福尔摩斯所扮演的角色。但它同时也提供了死后重生的希望，而这正是对灵媒主义的兴趣所做的事情。显然，随后它被第一次世界大战按下了涡轮增压键，对于许许多多的人来说都是如此。
For lots of people. The sense of loss. Conan Doyle becomes a public enthusiast for it in the same way that he's become a public spokesman for, say, sticking up for the British effort in the Burr War or for miscarriages of justice. He feels that it's his duty and responsibility to take a stand where other people are not. He thinks he's speaking up for what is right, doesn't he?
对于很多人来说。那种失落感。柯南·道尔公开热衷于此，就像他曾公开为英国在布尔战争中的努力辩护，或是为冤假错案仗义执言一样。他觉得当别人都不发声时，挺身而出是他的义务和责任。他认为自己在为正义发声，对吧？
He does. I mean, obviously, he completely believes it. And what's interesting is, of course, that Holmes has no time for ghosts. So there's the Sussex vampire, which has all kinds of fascinating lines for anyone who's interested in Conan Doyle's spiritualism. Holmes literally says, no ghosts need apply. But you see, that is the mistake that people make, isn't it? They equate Holmes and his creator. But Conan Doyle created Holmes as a portrait of, as a version of Joseph Bell, not of himself. I mean, he's more Dr. Watson, actually. And by creating Holmes as a sceptic, he doesn't mean that he's Bell, not of himself. I mean, he's more Dr. Watson, actually. And by creating Holmes as a sceptic,
他确实这么认为。我的意思是，很显然，他是完全坚信这一点的。有趣的是，福尔摩斯对鬼魂是完全不屑一顾的。比如《苏塞克斯吸血鬼》（The Sussex Vampire）中，对于任何对柯南·道尔的灵媒主义感兴趣的人来说，里面都有各种引人入胜的台词。福尔摩斯直截了当地说，鬼魂免谈。但你看，这就是人们犯的错误，不是吗？他们把福尔摩斯和他的创造者等同起来了。但柯南·道尔创造福尔摩斯，其实是以约瑟夫·贝尔（Joseph Bell）为蓝本进行的艺术塑造，而不是他自己。我的意思是，他其实更像是华生医生。他把福尔摩斯塑造成一个怀疑论者，并不意味着他自己
he doesn't mean that he's a sceptic himself. I mean, he can be quite critical of Holmes, in a way, as the creator of the stories. And I also think that Conan Doyle probably thought, if you put him on the spot with this very question, he would say there is no contradiction between science and spiritualism, because spiritualism merely represents a form of higher knowledge
也是个怀疑论者。我的意思是，作为故事的创作者，他其实可以对福尔摩斯颇有微词。我也觉得，如果你拿这个问题当面质问柯南·道尔，他大概会说，科学与灵媒主义之间并不存在矛盾，因为灵媒主义仅仅代表了一种更高阶的知识形式，
that we haven't attained yet yeah and then the two are not intention at all he's interested in scientific service so that's the um the cottony fairies which is well that's obviously the disastrous for him isn't it i mean photographs of girls with fairies which turn out not to be but he's he's approaching that as as homes might uh yeah it's just that his powers of deduction are not quite as good as Holmes'. Well, you've eliminated everything else. What remains must be the truth or whatever. But what he hasn't really eliminated is the prospect
是我们尚未企及的知识。是的，所以这两者根本不冲突。他对科学服务很感兴趣——所以这就是考丁利妖精（Cottingley Fairies）事件，这显然对他是个灾难，对吧？也就是那些拍到小仙子的女孩们的照片，最后证明是假的。但他接触这件事的方式就像福尔摩斯可能会做的那样……是的，只不过他的推理能力没福尔摩斯那么强。好吧，你排除了所有其他可能性。剩下的必然是真相，诸如此类。但他真正没有排除的可能性是：
that these are clearly cardboard cutouts. I mean, I was having a look at the photographs of Ferris this morning, and I thought to myself, I mean, they're living in a world kind of awash with photography at this stage. I mean, I know photography is expensive and it's more difficult, but they're very familiar with photographs. And even by the standards of 1920, these are quite obvious. Well, Dominic, there's one other dimension of famous fakery,
这些显然是纸板剪影。我的意思是，今天早上我看了看那些仙子的照片，我心里想，我的意思是，他们当时生活在一个到处充斥着摄影技术的时代。我知道摄影很贵，也更困难，但他们对照片非常熟悉。即便按1920年的标准来看，这些照片也未免太显而易见了。好吧，多米尼克，还有一个著名的造假维度，
which Conan Doyle is very kind of obliquely drawn into, which is the case of the Piltdown Man. A great historical story. So tell me about that. So Piltdown Man, the context for this is the discovery in France and Germany of prehistoric humans. So Neanderthals famously in Germany and what come to be called Cro-Magnon Man in France. And the British feel
柯南·道尔非常间接地被卷入了其中，那就是皮尔当人（Piltdown Man）骗局。一个重大的历史故事。快跟我讲讲。所以关于皮尔当人，其背景是在法国和德国发现了史前人类。著名的有德国的尼安德特人，以及法国所谓的克罗马农人。英国人感到
left out. You know, they're annoyed that the French and the Germans have early hominids. Where are ours? And the answer to that, of course, is that basically Britain is buried beneath ice, so there aren't nearly as many. But there is a sense that the challenge has been raised. Britain has to find an early hominid. And in due course, 1912, fragments of an early hominid are found in a quarry in Sussex, in a village called Piltdown, very close to where Conan Doyle is living. And these fragments are found by a solicitor called Charles Dawson. He presents a paper saying, you know, these are early hominids. All the British scientists are delighted.
被冷落了。你知道的，他们很恼火，为什么法国人和德国人都有早期人类化石，而我们的在哪儿？而答案当然是，基本上英国的大部分土地都被冰层覆盖，所以化石数量没那么多。但人们有一种挑战已经发出的感觉。英国必须找到早期人类化石。到了1912年，在萨塞克斯郡一个名为皮尔当（Piltdown）的村庄的一个采石场里——非常靠近柯南·道尔居住的地方——人们真的发现了早期人类的碎片。这些碎片是由一个名叫查尔斯·道森（Charles Dawson）的律师发现的。他发表了一篇论文称，这些是早期人类化石。所有的英国科学家都欣喜若狂。
So they call it Aeoanthropus Dawsoni, the dawn ape of Dawson. And over the course of the succeeding months and then the next couple of years up to the start of the first world war more and more finds are made and the most the most the most ludicrous of these finds is and i'm sorry to bring the subject up again a cricket bat an ancient cricket bat made Made out of elephant bone. And it seems astonishing that people haven't figured out that this is all a massive fraud, but people want to believe it. Are they claiming that Stone Age men played cricket? That seems to be the implication,
于是他们将其命名为道森黎明人（Aeoanthropus Dawsoni）。在随后的几个月以及直到第一次世界大战爆发的头两年里，人们发现了越来越多这样的化石。而其中最荒谬的发现是——抱歉，我又要提起这个话题了——一根板球棒，一根用象骨制成的古代板球棒。人们居然没有看出这全是一场巨大的骗局，这简直令人震惊，但人们太想相信它了。他们是在声称石器时代的人打板球吗？这似乎就是他们的暗示，
that people were playing cricket back in the Ice Age. And it's not until after the Second World War that finally it conclusively gets proven that this was all a fake. So the likeness identity of the faker is obviously Charles Dawson, this guy who's discovering it. But you still have to wonder,
暗示人们早在冰河时期就在打板球了。直到第二次世界大战之后，这最终才被确凿地证明全是一场骗局。所以，造假者的真实身份显然就是查尔斯·道森，这个发现化石的人。但你仍然不得不纳闷：
where's the cricket bat coming from? And you think this is kind of Doyle. So one theory, the theory that I think is the most convincing is that it's a guy called Martin Hinton, who's a volunteer at the Natural History Museum, who works out that it's a fake and basically comes up with a cricket bat as a way to completely make it all ludicrous so that people will just give up. But it doesn't work. But it doesn't work. It's brilliant. is that it was Conan Doyle who was trying to, you know, who was kind of playing Moriarty, that he was putting out
这根板球棒是打哪儿来的？你觉得这很符合柯南·道尔的风格。所以有一种理论——我认为最令人信服的一种理论——认为是一个名叫马丁·辛顿（Martin Hinton）的人干的，他是自然历史博物馆的一名志愿者，他发现这是个假货，于是基本上弄出了一根板球棒，以此把整个事件彻底搞得荒谬无比，好让大家放弃。但这并没有奏效。但这并没有奏效。太绝了。就是柯南·道尔试图……你知道的，他当时在扮演莫里亚蒂的角色，他释放出
misleading people and that the cricket bat was put in as a clue to his identity. I don't see Conan Doyle doing that because Conan Doyle is quite straight, isn't he? He plays a straight bat. Yes, very good. Yeah, he does. I don't see Conan Doyle doing
误导人们的信息，而那根板球棒是作为暗示他身份的线索放进去的。我不认为柯南·道尔会那样做，因为柯南·道尔为人相当正直，不是吗？他打球很光明磊落。是的，非常对。是的，他确实如此。说实话，我不觉得柯南·道尔会做出那种事。
that, to be honest with you. So I said it was tangential. Yeah, no, it's a good story. It's a great story. Just before we do a couple of questions and then call it a day, I think one of the fascinating things about Sherlock Holmes is its afterlife, obviously, so in films and so on. And I think what's very unusual is that it creates this industry
所以我才说这只是个题外话。对的，这确实是个好故事。是个绝佳的故事。在我们在回答几个问题然后收工之前，我觉得福尔摩斯最迷人的地方之一，显然是它的后续影响，比如在电影等等作品中。而且我认为很不寻常的是，它催生了一个庞大的产业，
in which people write Holmes pastiches and things. And actually, often the people who are very interested in this period will do that. So Nicholas Meyer wrote a book called The 7% Solution where Holmes meets Sigmund Freud. Michael Dibdin wrote a brilliantly dark book called The Last Sherlock Holmes Story about Holmes and Jack the Ripper.
人们争相撰写福尔摩斯的续篇和仿作。实际上，对这一时期非常感兴趣的人往往会这么做。尼古拉斯·迈耶（Nicholas Meyer）就写了一本书叫《百分之七溶液》（The 7% Solution），讲的是福尔摩斯遇到了西格蒙德·弗洛伊德。迈克尔·迪布丁（Michael Dibdin）写了一本极其黑暗的书《福尔摩斯最后一案》（The Last Sherlock Holmes Story），讲述了福尔摩斯和开膛手杰克的故事。
Well, Jack the Ripper. I was going to mention Jack the Ripper because in a sense, the afterlife of Jack the Ripper is a riff on Sherlock Holmes. It is. It absolutely is. I mean, the fog, the alleys, the sort of sense of opium dens in the background.
好吧，开膛手杰克。我正要提到开膛手杰克，因为从某种意义上说，开膛手杰克的后续影响正是对福尔摩斯的一种戏仿和致敬。确实如此。完全就是。大雾弥漫的街道、逼仄的小巷、背景中弥漫的鸦片馆气息。
So that's 1888. So that's a couple of years after studying Scarlet. It's absolutely of the period, isn't it? But I think the whole, because we had Hallie Rumenhold on, who wrote a brilliant book, Five, about the victims. And one of the reasons why the victims get occluded is because it's all about the villain
所以那是1888年。也就是《血字的研究》（A Study in Scarlet）发表后几年。这完全属于那个时代，对不对？但我认为整个……因为我们曾请到哈莉·鲁门霍尔德（Hallie Rubenhold）做客，她写了一本关于五名受害者的精彩著作《五人》（Five）。而受害者之所以常常被忽视的原因之一，正是因为故事的焦点全放在了罪犯身上，
and supposedly the person hunting him. So it's essentially the template is Holmes and Moriarty being wrapped up. It absolutely is. And I think we didn't really talk about Moriarty much. It's really interesting that Moriarty actually features so little in the home stories. I mean, I think he's pretty much only in the episode
以及据称正在追捕他的人。所以其基本模板就是福尔摩斯与莫里亚蒂的缠斗。完全是这样。而且我觉得我们之前没有怎么谈论莫里亚蒂。很有意思的是，莫里亚蒂在福尔摩斯原作中其实出场极少。我的意思是，我记得他基本上只出现在
of the Reichenbach Falls story. Yeah. That he has come to overshadow the series to such an extent. And I think obviously the fact that he's called Moriarty gives you some indication of the anxieties of Conan Doyle. Conan Doyle is a Liberal Unionist. And the reason the Liberal Unionists broke from the Liberal Party is they have a home rule for Ireland.
《莱辛巴赫瀑布》（The Reichenbach Falls）的故事那一集里。然而他却对整个系列产生了如此深远的影响，甚至喧宾夺主。而且显而易见，他被命名为莫里亚蒂，这从某种程度上暗示了柯南·道尔内心的焦虑。柯南·道尔是一名自由党联合派。自由党联合派之所以从自由党分裂出去，是因为他们主张爱尔兰自治。
And I think it's no coincidence that he's called Moriarty. So he's both of London and not of it. He's not Indian. He's not Afghan. But he's Irish. And I think that's one reason why he, there's something in him. And there's the idea of that super criminal as well. Obviously that's very much.
我认为他叫莫里亚蒂绝非巧合。所以他既属于伦敦，又不属于伦敦。他不是印度人。他不是阿富汗人。但他是个爱尔兰人。我想这也是为什么他……他的内心深处总有某种情结。还有那种超级罪犯的概念。显然这非常具有……
Napoleon of crime. Napoleon of crime. Exactly. But yeah, the way that Holmes has created this, this industry. So we had a question about Holmes creating fandom. And I think that's probably right.
犯罪界的拿破仑。犯罪界的拿破仑。正是如此。不过，福尔摩斯催生了这样一个庞大的产业……我们曾收到一个关于福尔摩斯如何创造“同人饭圈文化”的问题。我想这大概没错。
The Baker street irregulars, the first Sherlock Holmes society was set up in New York in 1934. So it's basically the first fan club. Anyway, let's do a couple of questions, shall we? Yep. We've got a question about illustrations. Cora Beth, how much do you think Paget's illustrations contributed
贝克街游击队（The Baker Street Irregulars），第一个福尔摩斯迷俱乐部于1934年在纽约成立。所以它基本上是世界上第一个粉丝俱乐部。无论如何，我们来回答几个问题吧？好的。我们有一个关于插画的问题。科拉·贝思（Cora Beth）问，你认为佩吉特（Paget）的插画对这些故事的成功贡献有多大？
to the success of the stories? Massively, right? The look of Holmes, yeah. Yes, because it's Paget who creates the look of Holmes. It's a bit like Dracula. He doesn't wear it. Bela Lugosi doesn't correspond to Bram Stoker's description. And Paget's portrayal of Sherlock Holmes doesn't correspond really to Conan Doyle's.
巨大的贡献，对吧？福尔摩斯的经典形象，是的。是的，因为正是佩吉特塑造了福尔摩斯的银幕（及纸面）形象。这有点像《德古拉》（Dracula）。他并不是那个样子的。贝拉·卢戈西（Bela Lugosi）的外貌与布拉姆·斯托克（Bram Stoker）的描述并不相符。而佩吉特对福尔摩斯的描绘其实也与柯南·道尔的描写不尽吻合。
But there's an interesting story about Pgett that apparently the guy who commissioned him thought that he was getting another Padgett, who was the illustrator for some magazine on the expedition to rescue General Gordon. Is that so? Yeah. And it was the wrong Padgett. And they got the wrong one. So it's like Scoop. Yeah.
不过关于佩吉特有一个有趣的故事，据说当年委托他作画的那个人以为自己找的是另一个佩吉特，那是某本杂志派往营救戈登将军（General Gordon）远征队的插画师。是吗？是的。结果找错佩吉特了。他们找错了人。这简直就像《独家新闻》（Scoop）里的情节。
Yeah, that's a very good story. But that's crucial. I mean, the deerstalker and the the pipe the pipe which he never smokes i think in the um or not much in the in the stories because that's why homes is so internationally famous is that you can just put a pipe and a deerstalker and everyone knows yeah but that that's your superhero analogy isn't it that he has a costume um which i think is is often crucial to the success of these characters particularly when they move on to celluloid um what about uh the modern sherlock holmes so chilton hundred did stephen moffat ruin sherlock by turning him into a kind of james bond superhero or is that dynamic present in the stories all along so this is the sort of
是的，这真是一个非常棒的故事。但这至关重要。我的意思是，猎鹿帽和烟斗——虽然他在小说中其实很少抽烟，或者说在故事里抽得不多——正是因为这一点，福尔摩斯才得以享誉全球。你只要画一个烟斗和一顶猎鹿帽，每个人就都知道他是谁了。是的，但这就像是你的超级英雄类比，不是吗？他拥有标志性的行头，我认为这对于这些角色的成功往往至关重要，特别是当他们被搬上大银幕的时候。那么现代版的福尔摩斯呢？切尔滕纳姆的一位听众问：史蒂芬·莫法特（Steven Moffat）把福尔摩斯变成了一种詹姆斯·邦德式的超级英雄，是不是把这个角色给毁了？还是说这种动态关系原本就贯穿于原著故事之中？所以这就是那种
very 21st century um modernized version of Sherlock Holmes has been incredibly popular not just in Britain but all over the world what do you think of this Tom um I thought the um that the early episodes were fantastic and clever and knowing and witty and you could enjoy them if you didn't know the stories and if you did your your knowledge of them was enormously enhanced um I I thought that a bit like Doctor Who, it ended up becoming a complete mess. Yeah. There were too many subplots,
非常21世纪的、现代化改编的福尔摩斯版本，不仅在英国，而且在全世界都大受欢迎。汤姆，你对此怎么看？呃，我觉得……早期的剧集简直棒极了，既聪明、懂行又机智风趣，即便你没读过原著也能看得津津有味；如果你读过原著，你的理解也会因此得到极大提升。我觉得……有点像《神秘博士》（Doctor Who）一样，它到头来变成了一团彻底的乱麻。是的。支线情节太多了，
too many people dying and coming back to life and all kinds of things. It became a tremendous muddle. Yeah, I actually didn't like it. You'd expect that of a professional grump, I mean, I suppose. I do. Yes, I do. I'm not at all surprised.
太多人死去又复活，各种乱七八糟的事情。最后变得一团糟。是的，其实我并不喜欢。考虑到你是个专业的爱抱怨者，这倒也在意料之中，我想是的。我确实是。是的。我一点也不觉得惊讶。
Have you seen Lupo? No, I haven't. It's really good. I think better. Right, okay. It's obviously modelled on it. They're not paying you, Tom. No, they're not.
你看过《亚森·罗宾》（Lupin）吗？没有，我没看过。真的很好看。我觉得比那个更好。好吧。显然它是模仿那个拍的。他们可没花钱找你做广告，汤姆。不，他们没有。
They're not. But obviously, if people want to send me free copies of Lupin, feel free. I'm an influencer. You are an influencer. I'm here for hire. I'm here for hire. The business with biscuit tea is shocking and shameful.
确实没有。不过，如果有人想给我寄几本免费的《亚森·罗宾》，尽管寄来。我可是个带货网红。你确实是个网红。我是待价而沽的。我是随时可以接单的。拿饼干茶做文章简直是令人震惊和耻辱。
I've seen piles of it now. Do they keep sending you every time you mention it on the podcast? Biscuit tea. Biscuit tea. Let's see. Bye, guys. Can I end on a personal note? Do.
我现在已经看到堆成山的饼干茶了。每次你在播客里提到它，他们就会一直给你寄吗？饼干茶。饼干茶。咱们看看吧。再见，各位。我能以一句私人感慨结束吗？请便。
Is it going to be very moving? No, it's not. Okay. But it's to do with where I live in Brixton. And Study in Scarlet is set in a house in brixton lauriston gardens and i i'd always look it up in the a to z couldn't find it couldn't work out where it was and then tony our producer sent me a message um about i don't know a couple of months ago saying guess where i am i'm in max roach park which is where the study in Scarlet was set.
这会非常感人吗？不，并不会。好吧。但这与我住在布里克斯顿（Brixton）有关。而且《血字的研究》故事发生地就在布里克斯顿的劳里斯坦花园（Lauriston Gardens）的一栋房子里。我以前总是在伦敦地图册（A-to-Z）里查这个地方，怎么都找不到，也搞不清它到底在哪儿。然后我们的制作人托尼给我发了一条消息……呃，大概是几个月前，说：“猜我在哪儿？我在马克斯·罗奇公园（Max Roach Park），也就是《血字的研究》里案发的地方。”
And it turns out that Laurison Gardens never existed. But from the description of it, it's a house that was set back from Brixton Road that then got, these all got demolished and they put a park up and it's now called Max Roach Park. So that is where Sherlock Holmes begins. And so this is just a shout out to Tony, our producer. Everyone knows the massive Sherlock Holmes. He's a very big Sherlock Holmes fan. Yes. You know what, Tom?
结果证明劳里斯坦花园根本不存在。但根据对它的描述，那是一栋从布里克斯顿路（Brixton Road）退进里面去的房子，后来这些都被拆了，建起了一个公园，现在就叫马克斯·罗奇公园。福尔摩斯的故事就是从那里开始的。所以这要特别向我们的制作人托尼致敬。大家都知道他是福尔摩斯的超级铁粉。他是个名副其实的福尔摩斯大粉丝。是的。你知道吗，汤姆？
You're a great man for these walks, aren't you? You love a walk. And I know- We're going to do a Sherlock Holmes walk. We should do a podcast of a Sherlock Holmes walk. I mean, basically, if you're not interested in Sherlock Holmes, too bad. But if you are,
你真的很喜欢散步，对吧？你可太爱散步了。而且我知道——我们要去进行一次福尔摩斯主题漫步。我们应该把福尔摩斯主题漫步录成一期播客。我的意思是，基本上，如果你对福尔摩斯不感兴趣，那太遗憾了；但如果你感兴趣的话，
for the three remaining listeners who've stuck with us to the end of the podcast, you really do have a treat to look forward to. That'd be a great idea. Let's do that. Sherlock Holmes walk. Tom loves these walks. He's already thinking about it, even as I speak. I am.
对于坚持收听我们播客到最后的寥寥几位忠实听众来说，你们真的有一场精彩的体验可以期待。这绝对是个好主意。咱们就这么办。来一次福尔摩斯漫步。汤姆最喜欢这种散步了。就在我说话的时候，他脑子里就已经开始盘算这事了。我确实在想。
That's very, very fun. The phone is going, so I think I should call it a day. The game's afoot. Goodbye. Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com.
这真的非常有意思。电话一直在响，所以我想我们今天就到此为止吧。好戏开场了。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史其余部分》。想要获取加更节目、抢先收听、无广告体验以及我们的聊天社区权限，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。
That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。